and then i kind of work out the story
like for maurice
she was actually a character i did live
on stage for a while
and that's how i built her backstory and
that's probably why she hit the hardest
maybe because
she was the most worked out so there is
something to that
um you know getting the character fully
developed what what her goal is
what her backstory is what her
psychology is practicing it
the other ones that i've created lately
they've come up kind of organically
um like derek from tallahassee and
he's sort of uh just he's just a i spent
a year in florida
living in miami and you go you know you
go that that
that miam that's a miami guy i mean i'm
sorry that's a florida guy outside of
miami or in some parts of miami
that are sort of from the old world
miami and um they're just different man
and so it's an amalgamation of things
it's kind of thought out
it's kind of a vibe i've experienced
obviously is you know like they say if
you want to
do what you know like don't try to do
what you don't know do what's closest to
you so the greek guy obviously i'm greek
uh maurice is uh you know puerto rican i
grew up around puerto ricans dating
puerto ricans i'm from new york
it's part of the culture in new york uh
derek i lived in miami
so do what's closest to you do what you
know imitate if it's gonna be your dad
your mom
your girlfriend their family don't try
to do something foreign
um do something that's supposed to
unless you're an impressionist then you
know those guys just
watch impressions and do it so yeah i've
heard you say you'll work your
characters
on stage and then film them what are you
doing when you're working them on stage
working them on stage just riff with it
just rip it in that character
riffing that character get into the
psychology of that character that's
something
that is something i do it's like when i
and i've performed mauricio
many times for years live uh for her
fans and it's like
i'm gone like every thought i'm having
obviously there's a little there's uh
the wizard of oz is behind the curtain a
little bit
but i am fully committed like i'm
thinking like she would think
i'm seeing like there's no one you can't
be embarrassed you have to give yourself
over to the character
you can't say oh i'm embarrassed to say
this or think this or
you have to commit and be that person
you know be what they would say be who
they are and that's hard in today's
world because
you know unfortunately comics now
especially if you still care about tv
stuff are constantly thinking about what
you're saying
which is sort of the antithesis of what
funny is
so nobody becomes a comic to watch what
they say nobody's a class clown because
they said the
the right thing at the right time what
makes things funny is when
you say the thing that you'd probably be
most embarrassed to say
or the thing that uh is the wrong moment
that you know
someone who's inappropriate would say so
you know maurice is inappropriate
maurice
mr panos is inappropriate they're over
the top
characters that if you met them in real
life would be like this person is a
little too extra
so you have to be willing to be extra
and not feel embarrassed about it so
lose yourself in the psychology
of that exaggerated character and forget
your
inhibitions if you love comedy as much
as we do here at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch
more videos to get even more comedy tips